oh ! la police
je vais devoir vous controler
tu veux pas faire une photo
-oui
-voila
Sympa le grand journal cette année
c'est bon ca vous va
euh c'est un peu juste
vous avez pas en xs
toute façon c'est pas pour moi c'est pour un pote je teste pour lui
je peux vous faire un ourlet
j'arrive pas a marcher! J'ai trop mal aux pieds!
je vais être le seule mec sur le tapis rouge  comme ça
Se faire recaler du tapis rouge : done (fait)
Voila voila, bon bah finalement on est pas rentrés parce que euh ...
Le film était pas ouf
Ouais, de toute façon on voulait plus le voir
un kebab ?
bonjour!
Vous pouvez prendre une photo s'il vous plaît
nous deux avec vous
Heum...
Je suis pas sapé pour la
Je suis pas sapé aujourd'hui
Peut-être un autres jour
un autres jour
où je serais bien habillé d'accord
je peux en faire une aussi?
toi j'aime pas trop... Toi
je suis désolé.
j'aime pas ton visage
ça te dérange pas si je fais une photo avec ton mec?
Et pas toi!
Ha! Ben. Bien sûr ! Oui
*rires*
il y a mon étiquette
heu
Qui est totalement pas coupée!
Je m'en bat les c*******
ni*** le système
ni*** l'état
Hey! Il y a les keufs (policiers) partout
M'en bat les c******* moi
Viens me voir !
Je suis là moi je t'attends! Moi!
Tu sais pas d'où je viens!
Je viens du tiex!
*bruit de crachat*
*musique de gangster*
wouah!!
annulation de la photo!!
-ha ouai ca!  -ha d'accord okay!
Il y a des éjaculations  de ...de mer
T'as des trucs à nous offrir?
Des gâteaux et tout ... ?
*inspiration*
non! Moi si vous voulez j'ai des sacs à main
à 6 000 euros
ah! Tu les offres?
Non!!
Moi. Je suis pas très sacs à mains.
Ouais
Mais moi je suis sacs à mains
Beh! Achète toi en un alors!
Si t'as envie de me faire un cadeau
Moi aussi j'accepte
ha! La michtoneuse de Cannes Quoi!
Merci! Merci les mecs!
Super les contacts
super contact
Non! Mais si tu as envie je sais pas ?
Si t'as des sous à gaspiller!
j'ai pas envi!
Non?
pu****
Crois moi quand je mets des costards
On dirait je gratter ds aides à la CAf! Mon frère!
excusez moi! S'il vous plaît? Je m'habille et tout!
Je suis français! Hein!
*rire*
Est ce que vous avez déjà vu 15 mecs en costards?
Okay!!!!
-Tony!   -Tony!!
-comment tu vas?
c'est bien
-Ho! Tony !
Tu es beau
- Tony! Como Esta?
ca va
On a failli se faire un bisous sur la bouche !
donc c'est celui là soit disant
L'ordi le plus plat du monde ?
Je sais pas quoi?
Oui! En effet c'est celui la.
Et! C'est lequel celui-là la bas il est pas mal aussi?
Il est heu
il est pas mal hein! J'adore!
J'adore le ... Il est bien!!
Mon rap est tellement violent, qu'un cerf-volant
????
mon son est toujours actif, mon son t'envoie en soin palliatif
moi je viens du 88
moi j'ai vu que ... ouai ouai, t'as beaucoup d'abonné par rapport à moi
hahaha
Why do you want taking picture with me?  ( Pourquoi tu veux prendre une photo avec moi ?)
you don't know? ( tu ne sais pas? )
I like him ( je l'aime bien)
you like me? ( tu m'aime bien ?)
yes (oui)
hoo give me a hug (donne moi un câlin)
ok gros vent... bon aller au revoir, gros vent dans la gueule.
thank you very much, have a nice night
- ils font pas ça ! - ha ?! pas de bisous? pas de bisous?
putain deuxième vent, je me suis pris un double vent par heu voilà.
ça me fait plaisir, c'est quoi c'est la bouteille ou la meuf le cadeau?
c'est les deux , c'est les deux
moi je prend juste la meuf, ça m'intéresse pas l'alcool
ouai, donc comment tu t'appel?
tes vidéos j'en ai vu quelques une.
Sérieux? t'as mit un pouce en l'aire?
oui j'ai trouvé ça très drôle, j'aime bien ton humour
c'est un humour très sérieux tu vois?
on a un peu le même humour
c'est un humour sérieux? -ouai-
Et quand tu dis que tu aime mon humour c'est que tu veux sortir avec moi ou???
ouai carrément
attend dit pas ça parce que ça m'intéresse vraiment
et contre toute attente Norman monte finalement les marche de Canne
mais celle de la gare de Canne. La gare SNCF, pour rentrer chez lui
c'est quand même pas mal, pour ce youtuber .. de merde...